foreign
it seems that every week we hear about a
new Tick-Tock Trend they always have a
different name they're always annoying
and weird in slightly different ways but
the one thing that most of them have in
common is that they are very thinly
veiled excuses for being lazy The Tick
Tock Community Works hearted only one
thing and that is finding new ways to
make their laziness seem trendy and now
they have a new one it's called bed
rotting and it's as bad as it sounds CBS
News explains watch
there's a new tick tock Trend that could
trigger depression in some people and
it's got a rather interesting name I
know have you heard of this bed rotting
no it's not something that sounds like
something I would want to do right but I
guess people want to do it and it's
actually the practice of lying in bed
for long periods of time sometimes for
days while binge watching TV or
scrolling through social media and
eating of course now influencers tout it
as a form of self-care but experts say
the behavior is more typical of someone
who's depressed
once again the experts are on the scene
to point out the immensely obvious thank
God for the experts what will we ever do
without them
and we can certainly trust the experts
on this one as it turns out
it is not a healthy practice to become a
voluntary invalid actually it's better
for a human it turns out to to do things
like move around and walk and um maybe
get some sun on occasion if you're
getting less fresh air and exercise than
a prisoner in solitary confinement
that's a pretty good indication that
you're making some very poor life
choices
but then again how bad can your life
choices be if other people are doing the
same thing
have you ever heard of bed rotting is
something that I learned about last week
but it's something I've been doing for
years off and on and I didn't know it
had a name for it I just thought it was
like just depression and I'm sure you've
been doing this too it's a form of
self-care but you shouldn't do it too
often because apparently it can be
laziness but but basically it's where
you just sit or lay in bed all day you
can eat snacks watch Max but some of the
girlies they're like high tech and
high-end versions where they like do
skin care and some spa treatments just
from their bed normally in the past if I
stayed in bed all day I would feel so
guilty but now that I've learned that
this is a thing
I'm no longer going to feel guilty for
bed rotting
yes uh why feel guilty for being an
unwashed sedentary bum there are so many
other unwashed sedentary bombs after all
it's a thing it's a whole thing
how bad can a thing be if it's a thing
these are important philosophical
questions but bed rotting is somehow not
the worst or at least not the most
overtly grotesque Tick-Tock laziness
Trend to gain traction recently a
different but closely related trend is
called depression rooms
and the depression room phenomenon
involves tick tockers showing off their
cluttered filthy bug infested bedrooms
which have become unsightly garbage
heaps because of their depression
sometimes in the video they'll clean
their room and congratulate themselves
for performing this basic daily chore
for the first time in nine months in
other videos
um they make no attempt to clean and
they simply just give a tour of the
toxic waste dump that they sleep in
here's a one example of the genre
I've had a lot of people comment on my
room and how messy it is I'm pretty sure
it comes from the aunties who are like
are you proud of this you're disgusting
how can you let it get like this I'm not
proud of you know how messy I let my
room get I think if you have depression
or you suffer from depression or anxiety
or any kind of mental health disorder
you understand that sometimes we just
can't get up
she just can't she can't get up can't do
it she can record Tick Tock videos and
edit them and post them and scroll the
comments to see what people are saying
about them but she can't get up and
clean her room she just can't do it
until she does it of course but the
times that she doesn't do it it's
because she simply can this is a theme
that emerges in many of these videos uh
like this one
okay so I don't want to hear any slander
or any hate on this video because I know
a lot of you guys a lot of people in the
comments are going to deal with
something like this and I'm gonna give
you a sneak peek into my life
this is what happens when I get
particularly stressed or anxious or
depressed I cannot clean anything get
organized I can't do it
can't do it can't do it she's physically
incapable somehow in some way again this
is a this is a theme
by the way I'm fine I want to clean my
room really really badly I can't and I
know some of you are going to understand
that and some of you are just gonna get
up and do it just do it if you want to I
can't
does anyone know what I mean I can't
yeah some of us are going to say get up
and do it because that actually is the
answer just get up and do it stop
whining and do it you can do it you can
shut up and do it
uh so so that's why your room is filled
to the brim with useless junk that you
bought because you can't clean up after
yourself well I saw an Old Navy shopping
bag you somehow managed to go to Old
Navy Against All Odds you figured out
how to walk out of your house get into
your car drive the Old Navy walk around
Old Navy buy all those clothes with your
Dad's credit card you could do that
you weren't too physically immobilized
and crippled by your depression to do
that thing you wanted to do and yet when
it comes to things you don't want to do
somehow your depression turns into
paralysis what an interesting medical
phenomenon
I'm crippled by depression when I don't
want to do things
is a depression crippling you or are you
just laser that's called being lazy
that's like the definition of lazy
actually it's not a very interesting
phenomenon because again you're just
lazy I mean you may be depressed you may
not be but one thing you definitely are
is lazy let me ask you this
uh you say that you can't clean your
room what what if I walked up to you
with a giant bag filled with 10 million
dollars in cash and I said that I would
give it to you if you cleaned your room
10 million dollars right here I will
give it to you right now if you clean
the room
I bet you find a way to do it wouldn't
you see this is the difference between
things like depression ADHD anxiety and
something and you know something like
cancer or diabetes
because if I offered you 10 million
dollars to not have cancer anymore you
couldn't take me up on the offer no
matter how badly you wanted to but if I
offered you 10 million dollars to no
longer be crippled by depression you
would magically find a way the same goes
for ADHD and anxiety and similar
quote-unquote mental health disorders if
you feel properly incentivized and
interested you can become a functional
human being
you might walk around saying I can't do
this I can't do that I'm so depressed
and yet if the incentive was high enough
you'd figure out a way wouldn't you
it's like the parents who insist that
their 12 year old son has ADHD and can't
sit still and yet even as they make that
claim that very same son has been
sitting nearly motionless for five hours
in front of a TV playing video games he
can sit still it turns out it's just
that a lot of the times especially in
school he doesn't want to
this is an important point you know one
of the great curses of our age is that
people have been convinced that they
don't have agency they're not rational
conscious agents making choices and
acting freely in the world
the medicalization of every human foible
we talked about at the beginning every
bad feeling every unpleasant emotion
plays a big part of this people don't
want to do things or they don't feel
incentivized to do them and then they're
convinced that because of some kind of
invisible disease they can't do those
things
this is the main reason why objective
depression being categorized as a
disease depression is a feeling it's a
thought process you decide how much
power it gives has over your life
you decide that
the same cannot be said for other
diseases you have absolutely no power to
decide how say
hepatitis affects you you take medicine
you can do other things to try and
manage it but you can't use the force of
sheer willpower to mitigate its impact
on you yet that is exactly what you
could do with depression or anxiety or
one of these other things you can get
out of your bed and clean your room you
can do the thing you say you cannot do
you absolutely can there is nothing
physically preventing you you choose not
to
but you know the real problem with
chalking up all this to you know
depression is that it masks the real
epidemic that has a long-sense script
hold of American society in general and
especially the younger Generations uh
Zoomers are not depressed they are
apathetic and this may seem like a
distinction without a difference
except that depression is supposedly a
chemical function in the brain even
though the chemical imbalance theory has
been shown to be bunk
but the apathy choking the life out of
the youngest generation is a cultural
problem something ingrained in them
practically from birth
this is the thing that ties together bed
rotting and depression rooms and quiet
quitting and all the rest of it
not depression but a general
philosophical apathy annihilism they
don't care
they don't see meaning or purpose
it's a serious problem no question about
in fact it's much deeper than any kind
of chemical imbalance
and that's not the thing that's LED them
here but rather a life full of digital
stimulation yet devoid of any kind of
spiritual or moral formation
they don't really want anything they
have no goals not because they're so
deeply fulfilled but because they're so
deeply empty
now I don't say this applies to everyone
in gen Z but it's a widespread epidemic
one that extends far beyond their
generation of course
we've all heard these complaints from uh
employers who hire young people and say
that like they have no useful skills
but even worse they don't care enough to
learn the skills they just don't care
they don't care about anything
or at least they don't care about any of
the right things
now the good news is that this is a
problem
that can be overcome on an individual
level especially
it means that all the people lying
around complaining that they can't get
up they can't clean their room they
can't go to work they can't put an
effort they can't move out of their
parents house they can't become real
functioning adults they can't find true
success they can't find fulfillment of
Life they can't do this they can't do
that they can't they just can't
all of these people are mistaken they
can absolutely do all of that they could
do it starting tomorrow they could do it
starting right now this moment
they might be depressed but they can act
like they aren't and the great thing is
that in so many cases the more you act
like you aren't depressed the less
depressed you will be the more you act
like you care about the things in life
that you should care about the more you
will actually care the more you work
hard the more you will want to work hard
you just have to start you have to put
one foot in front of the other and start
doing it
and you can start especially
by getting out of bed
and cleaning your filthy room
and this is why bedrodding and
depression rooms are both today canceled
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed